[موسيقى]
حيث تعجز الكلمات عن الكلام ، فكتب
يدي كريستيان أندرسون
أنه كان من الممكن أن يتحدث عن ظهيرة يوم الأحد
في هذا المطعم على طول
الواجهة البحرية لنخلة جميرا بدبي
، حيث يستمتع
الرواد هنا بالفرقة الكوبية الحية
، وتشعر التجربة برمتها بخصوصية إضافية
بعد أيام الوحدة الطويلة.  2020.
الموسيقى الرائعة والطعام الفاخر
شركة الأصدقاء
لمشاركة العلمي ،
المدير الإداري لو كلاي للترفيه في دبي ،
إنها إحياء
للأعمال التجارية التي انهارت تمامًا
في ربيع عام 2020. كان
ذلك آخر مرة تحدثنا فيها أنها كانت واحدة من
أصواتنا  للأزمة لدينا فنانين
من جميع أنحاء العالم يأتون إلى
دبي كما تعلمون ، دبي هي
أم مزدحمة للغاية بها حياة ليلية ، لذلك كان علينا
أن نجد على الفور حلاً
لإعادتهم إلى بلدانهم ،
أم كان لدينا شعور بالمطارات
وكان السفر سيصبح مقيدًا ، لذا كان
مجرد قرار فوري
ووضع أزمة لفريقنا لإرسال
الجميع أثناء ذلك  هذا الوباء
هو أحد الفرق الموسيقية التي أرسلتها إلى المنزل ، نعم
بالضبط لقد عادوا إلى المنزل مارس 2020
ثم عادوا في ديسمبر ،
هل حصلت على الكثير من العمل لهم الآن
لدينا أربعة أو خمسة عروض في الأسبوع
لهم ويقومون بأعضاء أماكن مختلفة
مطاعم النادي حفلات الزفاف والفنادق
وحفلات العام الجديد ، لذلك نحن مشغولون
للغاية ونذهب إلى الاستوديو غالبًا ما
اكتشفت شارين خلال هذا الإغلاق الأول
أن خططها لتجربة
استمرار العمل عبر الإنترنت
لن تكون ناجحة ،
لقد كان صعبًا بعض الشيء نحن
نحن نتحدث أكثر عن تجربة تجربة
آه موسيقيًا للتواصل مع
فرقة تمر بلحظة أه ، لذا
اخترنا التركيز فقط على أه الانتظار
حتى تعود المدينة والعالم
إلى قدميها ونعيد
الترفيه الحي للجميع
لقد وصلت الآن omicron في ذروة دبي
أو موسم الذروة ، نعم
أه ما هي أشهر الشتاء ، نعم
كيف تدير الآن ، لذا لن أكذب
الأسبوع الماضي كان مرهقًا بعض الشيء خلال
العام الجديد نحن  جلب الكثير من
الأعمال الدولية من المملكة المتحدة من لندن
من باريس من كل مكان خلال
موسم الذروة المزدحم للغاية هذا ،
فنحن نوفر الفنادق والمطاعم ، لذلك
كان الأمر يمثل تحديًا بعض الشيء ولكننا نجحنا في
اجتيازه ولم
نقم بتزويدنا بكل ما لدينا  الخدمات لجميع
الفنادق والمطاعم ، نحن فقط
نتوخى الحذر الشديد ، وأعتقد أن هذا ما
يتعين علينا القيام به ، أعني أه نحن نعلم أنه هناك ،
نحتاج فقط إلى الانتظار ونرى ما
سيحدث ونرى ما
تعلنه الحكومة ونحن مستعدون أنا  فكر بعد
هذه السنتين الصعبتين لأي شيء في
هذه المرحلة
إلى حد ما ، فإن العمل التجاري الذي تعمل فيه
نعم معتاد على الأزمات التي لا
يحضرها الفنان لطائرة متأخرة ، ففشل الجهاز ،
إنه ليس جديدًا ، لا إنه ليس كذلك ولكن
هذا كان على
كانت هذه الوظيفة على نطاق واسع ، وهي
جزء من طبيعة الترفيه
لدينا عقد لمدة أسبوع واحد ليس لدينا
عقد في الأسبوع التالي ، نفقد حفلة
، أعتقد أن هذا هو الجمال
ولهذا السبب أحب  الترفيه
ليس كما كان  يومًا وأنت تعمل
مع هؤلاء الأشخاص الفنيين
والجميلين كل يوم والعملاء المحبوبين الذين
يدعموننا ويؤمنون بنا أيضًا
خلال هذه الأزمة ، ما هي المهارات
التي أدركتها ما هي الأعماق
التي كنت تعلمها عن نفسك جيدًا
لم أكن أبدًا  شخص صبور جدًا
تعلمت أنني بحاجة إلى التحلي بالصبر الشديد
وأقل اندفاعًا ، فقط ثق بنفسي
وبعض الأشياء خارجة عن
إرادتي تمامًا وإذا كان من المفترض أن يكون الأمر
كذلك وإذا كان من المفترض أن
ننجو من الوباء فسنبقى على قيد الحياة  هذا
الصبر هو
فضيلة لم يكن لديك ما لم يكن لدي ، أنا
حقا لست كذلك ، هل
أنت شخص لطيف ولطيف
كنتيجة لذلك تعتقد
أنني أعتقد أنني لن أتغير أبدًا
ابق على ما أنا عليه ، لقد كنت دائمًا
لطيفًا جدًا ، أنا سيدة أعمال لطيفة ، لكنني
أعتقد أنني أكثر صعوبة في المواقف الصعبة ،
فأنت تعرف نوعًا ما أكثر
في الحقيقة هذا ما يحدث
ليحدث ، خذها أو اتركها ، لا يمكننا أن نجد
مكانًا لها
أيضًا  تدرك الكثير من مشاركة المفاوضات أن
العمل محفوف بالمخاطر
بعد عامين من الصعود والهبوط ،
فقد أصبح عملنا رمزًا
للمرونة والقيمة التي
نوليها للأشياء الصغيرة التي أخذناها
كأمر مسلم به مثل الاجتماع معًا
والاستمتاع بالموسيقى الجيدة
ريتشارد كريست سي إن دبي